I'll tell you what's funny autistics
hilarious to me because we're doing if I
can paying that Saturday we gave me and
J overtime on this you Rogen and I gave
Eddie so much [ __ ] Oh with the Flynn
case and the Russian probe and all that
and we'd say he go it's fake news and
all this and was lying there feels like
[ __ ] up we look I remember the three
of us young Eddie Bauers shut the [ __ ]
up and I tweeted all this to tax off say
go you know it's Halle I lose laughing
yeah Eddie was right he was right this
whole time and he was right I know
frustrating we are with society not
getting these stats they got Eddie I
don't know it's like dude you don't know
what you're talking I were people in the
FBI who didn't want Trump to be present
at all costs and they overstepped their
bounds and they always they implicated
though they basically got Flynn to
perjure himself yeah and you were
supporting mr. channel 3 channel so you
guys were supporting the FBI is that
yeah and Eddie called out oh this is all
distraction yeah it's all [ __ ] when
I feel bad I'm P [ __ ] I'm so I kept
poking him I'm like Eddie tongue what
else that or else and then I just went
Brian and Joe to go out of it yeah
poking Eddie and Eddie must have been so
frustrated I feel so bad because I I
said I mean the FBI is not standing or
institution yeah and it's not a lot of
way more good bad guy it's just that you
had it you had a political there were
people in the FBI yeah at the upper
echelon who had a political agenda dude
how about those guys in is it Venezuela
those are kind of the black water boys
that went out and got caught I thought
about this yeah no you you haven't seen
this either
no James kornek all right that's what
ever year-old Jordans whatever your old
Blackwater yeah but black water boys
that's so black water well no they're a
version that will black water meaning
they weren't supported by the US
government
Oh former Rangers that decided trying to
get the Venezuela yeah they got caught
uh-huh and you hear everything went
wrong everything went wrong with a guy
cop even before they had to shore do you
hear what President Trump said he was
that defin wasn't us cuz
much different I would have sent a team
yeah yeah yeah yeah the guy was asserted
there literally everything went wrong
from me yeah like you're gonna go take
over a car but now they have the two
Green Berets and they can tell they're
under you know under stress because they
had a professional body reader and yeah
they keep like looking up and looking
around they have them read this stuff
and then I turn to de-stress man when
you save those boys here we go you know
who's happy Eddie Bravo this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]